- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today I'm going to talk about
the seven things you must do
to achieve your goals.
- [Computer Voice] Nine.
Eight.
(upbeat electronic music)
Seven.
- So one of the things I find
with a lot of entrepreneurs
is we set goals, right.
We have goals, upon goals, upon goals,
we have to-do lists a mile high
and we just keep setting goals
and we don't necessarily
actually follow through
or achieve them.
And so tody I'm going to share with you
my seven ways to actually
get your goals accomplished.
Number one is set the right goals.
This is really important.
A lot of times we don't
set the right goals for us.
We set the goals that
we think we should do
or that other people want for us,
but not the ones that are
actually right for us.
I think of an example
when I was listening to
an audiobook on goal setting
and the speaker was talking about,
in a really passionate manner,
write down all your goals.
If you want to be a painter,
write down create a masterpiece.
If you want to make a
sculpture, write that down,
create a sculpture.
If you want to write a score
for a song, write that down.
And we go, oh wow, that
sounds so interesting.
I want to do that.
I want to paint something, why not?
I want to make a sculpture.
Yeah, it's awesome.
And then I come back to it
and I realize, you know what?
I don't actually want to make a sculpture.
I got kind of wrapped up in the moment,
listening to the
excitement of this speaker,
but it wasn't something
that I actually deep down wanted to do
and so you really want to make sure
that the goals you set for yourself
are ones that even when you come back to
a week later, a month later,
still resonate with you.
Like, the goal has to mean something.
If you don't care about the goal
and actually accomplishing it,
or if you're doing it
just for somebody else
and it doesn't really
mean something to you,
then you're never going to follow through.
So I'd really force
you to audit your goals
and look at them and examine them
and think, do these actually excite me?
Do I have the right goals
that I want to build around
and then you can focus on worrying about
the steps to achieve them.
Number two is have an important why.
And this aligns closely
with the first one.
Why is this so important?
Why is it so important that you go out
and accomplish that goal?
It has to come from a deep reason
that really resonates with you,
otherwise it's just
going to be a wishlist.
And we all have a wishlist.
We all have, again, that
to-do list that's a mile high
and the ones that you actually, deeply,
meaningfully care about,
you have a strong why attached to it,
those are the ones that
you're going to do.
Too often, though, we only do the things
that we're forced to do.
You do it because a
customer is asking for it,
or you do it because, you know,
somebody in your family
is forcing you to do it.
You don't actually do it because
you have a deep why for it
and so really important is
when you look at your goals,
attaching a strong why to each one.
If you can't figure one
out, then drop the goal
because you're never going to get it done.
It's just going to
continue to be a wishlist
and we want to move it from the wishlist
to actually a list of goals
that we're going to accomplish.
Number three is take daily action.
If this is important to you
that you accomplish this goal
then you have to schedule it in daily.
Look at your calendar
and schedule time for it to happen daily.
It doesn't have to be a ton of time.
Doesn't mean that you now have
five hours a day to spend on this,
but everyday you need to
take some kind of action,
even if it's small,
at least half and hour,
moving forward on your goal,
especially if you're doing this part time.
You have a full-time job, you
have a family to take care of,
you've got lots of demands for your time,
you need to carve out the time.
If you don't carve out the
time to accomplish your goals,
the rest of your life will take over.
It would happen there's this
theory of big rocks first.
Image you've got sand, you've got pebbles
and you've got big rocks.
If you put the sand in first,
and then the pebbles and you
put the big rocks into a jar,
it won't all fit together.
It's going to overflow.
But if you put the big rocks in first,
then the pebbles will come in
and will fit around the big rocks,
and then the sand will come in
and fit around the pebbles
and it will all fit into the jar.
That jar is your schedule.
If you're constantly just
doing the little things,
which is the sand and then the pebbles,
you never have time to do the big things,
which are your rocks.
If this is important to you,
then you put the big rocks in first.
Adjust your calendar,
adjust your schedule,
so that the things that
you want to accomplish,
that are on that goal list,
are in your weekly calendar,
so that you're doing
something consistently on it.
And then the rest of life
will be the pebbles and sand
and will find ways to take up your time,
but you need to defend
that time in your calendar
to work on the important goals.
Number four is commit to somebody else.
You're way more likely to
follow through on something
when you commit to somebody else.
When you tell a friend,
family member, a colleague,
that you are going to do something,
you're much more likely to do it.
You know, I told Jason
I'm going to be here
at 8:30 in the morning to film this video,
I showed up here at 8:30 in the morning.
When you don't commit to somebody else,
when it's just you committing to yourself,
you're really likely to let yourself down.
We are not great accountability
partners for ourselves.
We will let ourselves down constantly.
And so when you can
commit to somebody else,
your chances of achieving
your goal go up dramatically.
So you could do it through a buddy system,
you know, maybe have a spouse
that you want to do this with,
maybe you have a friend that
you want to do this with,
maybe there's somebody
else in your industry
that you want to do this with,
where you have your monthly
goals or weekly goals
and you connect.
You may do it through a mastermind group.
That's what I do for myself.
We've got eight people
in a mastermind group
and we meet, physically, once per month
to talk about our goals,
and then every member is partnered up
with somebody else in the group
and every week you have
a phone call with them.
It could be just 10, 15-minute
phone call once a week,
to make sure that you do the things
that you say you're going to do.
So here's what I want to get done
before our meeting next month.
And then you have a weekly call
to say how you're making
forward progress on it or not.
And what you hate doing is
reporting to your partner
that you didn't do it.
And so having that weekly accountability
helps makes sure that you're
making forward progress
and sometimes that person
needs to hold your hand a little bit
needs to light a fire under
your butt a little bit.
Just depends on the role.
Depends where you're at.
But having an accountability partner,
committing to someone else
to say you're going to do it
and having them hold your
feet to the fire a little bit,
helps make sure that you're
going to accomplish your goals.
Number five is model success.
One of my favorite things to do
to accomplish any goal
is to model success.
I find somebody who's already accomplished
what I want to do, figure
out what worked for them,
and then try it in my business.
This is what saved my first company.
At the beginning I had
to do everything myself.
I tried to come up with
every new idea myself.
I thought I was a creative person
and I could solve this problem.
And I could solve a lot of problems,
but you know what's even faster,
is finding someone else
that's already solved it
and then just tweak their
system to make it work for you.
You know, Starbucks was
started because Howard Schultz
went to Milan in Italy and
saw how the coffee shop
was the center of life in Italy,
it was the third home, between home, work,
it was the third meeting spot.
And he looked at North America and he saw
like the Dunkin' Donuts of the world,
where it's just in and out,
you don't really spend any
time in a Dunkin' Donuts.
And he said I want to bring
this Italian way of living
to North America, and
then later to the world.
And it worked.
Like, all he did to build a
multi-billion dollar empire,
one of the biggest brands in the world,
was model what worked
in a different market
and brought it to North America.
Whatever problem you're facing right now
to achieving your goal,
somebody has already done it.
Look to them.
Understand their success.
The bigger they are, the
easier it is to find out
the early days, right.
And that's what you want to figure out.
How Howard Schultz opens
another Starbucks right now
is not interesting.
How he went from like zero to one,
how did he build those first few stores,
how did they make their first million,
that is super interesting.
And so that's what you need to model
to help you accomplish your goals.
Number six is bring on a team.
As soon as you can afford it,
you want to be able to bring on a team
to help you accomplish your goal
because the bigger the goal is,
the more people you're going to need.
And I think a lot of people
have it in their head
that you need to hire somebody full time
and that's going to cost
X thousand dollars a year.
You don't.
The first guy I hired for my business,
I hired for one hour a day.
And that saved me more
than one hour a day of time
because he was better at
doing the job than I was
and it freed up my time
to go off and do more important things
to help me build my business.
So as soon as you're starting
to make any kind of money,
it doesn't have to be a
lot of money, anything,
I would take a good portion of that
and invest it back into
bringing on somebody to help me,
even if it was for one hour a day,
or a couple hours a week,
so that you can make forward
momentum and forward progress.
You can't do this alone.
You can't.
If you have a big goal,
it's not going to happen with
just you doing everything
and so the faster you can get
used to bringing on a team,
the better and also as a side benefit,
helps build up your leadership skills
so that you're getting
used to managing a team
because you're going to
make a lot of mistakes too.
If you've never managed people before,
you're going to make a ton of mistakes,
and better that it happens
on a really small scale
and you learn from it and get better
than if it really now becomes important
because you've hired somebody full time
and it has to work.
And number seven is enjoy the process.
I've talked about this
a lot on the channel.
It has to be important to you
that it's not just about
achieving the goal,
but it's about enjoying the
work on the way to the goal.
It's super important.
You can only force yourself
to do something for so long
before you give up and you quit.
If you don't enjoy the
work of what you're doing
and your only goal is
achieving that outcome,
you're going to fail.
You're going to fail because
you don't enjoy the work.
With the successful people
who are high achievers
and achieve their goals,
they like the work as well.
The goal is almost secondary
to the actual work.
Like, my goal to hit a
million YouTube subscribers
is a good goal, it's a
next kind of logical step
after hitting 100,000.
Great, like, here's our goal,
but much more important than
hitting the million subscribers
is this, is this getting better,
is me enjoying the process of filming
and working on how do we get
the videos out there better
and how do we improve the
whole experience for everybody.
Like that's what really, really,
really ultimately drives me
much more than just
hitting the one million.
Because when we hit a million,
there'll be a little win,
like, great, hey a million,
we get a new gold plaque or
whatever YouTube sends you.
Okay, let's keep going, right.
Like, I'm not done.
Like, a million is nothing.
We got to keep going, keep building,
keep helping entrepreneurs
and so the process is more
important than the goal.
The goal helps you align your
process a little bit better
if that's the goal you
really want to accomplish.
For me to hit a million subscribers,
then I have to do certain work,
I have to focus on bigger picture things
on my YouTube channel,
and continue to make
improvements to get better,
but that's the work that I love doing.
And so make sure that
you are picking goals
where you are not just
excited about the goal,
but you're excited about the work
that goes into achieving the goal as well.
So those are my suggestions
for the seven things
you must do to accomplish your goal.
I'd love to know, what do you think?
Which one resonated the most with you?
Which one do you need the most help with?
And did I miss an eight, nine, 10
that you want to add to the list?
Help out Believe Nation, show some love,
leave it down in the comments below.
Super curious to hear what you have to say
and will join in the discussion.
Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.